recibir las clases virtuales ha sido un
poco ha sido muy diferente la verdad a
veces si uno no entra con trabajo tiempo
no se da cuenta lo que tuvieron menos
estrés a todo
por dicha es mejor estar en la casa yo
siento y no tener que levantarme demás
temprano todos los días
el colegio
si lo extraño a veces si ella me entra
como la nostalgia de lo que era antes
como lo que era ir a comer con mis
amigos y si lo extraño bastante
hemos hecho más actividades como familia
que por ejemplo jugar y juegos de mesa
hacer tener nuestras charlas en la
comida hablar sobre temas y ha sido muy
bueno la verdad hemos teníamos
comunicación después de todo el colegio
de todos los trabajos pintar es como mi
fuente de expresarme con esta realidad
que estamos viviendo ha sido complicado
y muchas emociones han pasado por mi
cabeza y ansiedad es una de ellas
actualmente sí con la selección nacional
de costa rica lado 16 y el 15 yo ya no
puedo ir a gimnasios ya no voy a una
cancha en la que corrí vuelvo corrí
vuelvo ahora tengo que estar acá que
gracias a dios mis papás me lo han
podido acondicionar para mi
entrenamiento personal
lo más difícil
todo esto ha sido como acostumbrarme el
cambio que se ha dado de mis
entrenamientos
de todo
lo mejor ha sido que por fin tengo un
aro en las casas